hallo mein vater ist gestorben
man kann die schauspielerin dyan krüger
aus vielen gründen bewundern
am meisten vielleicht dafür dass sie es
immer wieder schafft auch kleine und
mittelmäßige rollen wirklich zum
leuchten zu bringen
also woher kommst du
[Musik]
mein einziges zu hause also gefühlt
dafür eine zeitlang israel und das gilt
auch für den film die agenten des
israelischen regisseurs uva radler der
jetzt ins kino
meine mutter hat immer davon gesprochen
sie war freiwillig in einem kibbuz in
den siebzigern
das war damals für durch eine ziemlich
große darin eine engländerin mit
internationalen wurzeln die für den
israelischen geheimdienst mossad einen
spezialauftrag in der iranischen
hauptstadt ist er als mann wurde war sie
nur eine gewöhnliche agentin
da bist du ja es war meine idee sie in
den iran zu schicken
du bist perfekt für diesen auftrag sie
war zielstrebig und wollte etwas
bedeutsames leisten
ich vertraute ihr fahrrad razavi wurde
ihre zielpersonen stellen sie kinzel
tipps und das gelingt ihr aufs schönste
indem sie diesen mann nicht nur zu sein
zu ihrem englisch schüler macht als
englischlehrerin das ist ihre tarnung
hätte sich überhaupt im iran auf sondern
auch zu ihrem geliebten entsprechen
erzählen sie mir von sich ach das ist
okay bern sda
sie machen sich die regeln einfach so
passiert ja tut mir leid die regeln hier
sind sie und präsentiert diese
ambivalenz von liebe und sexualität
etwas persönliches die kennen wir aus
vielen agentenfilmen und auch hier wird
sie von den krüger auf glänzende und
wunderbarste dargestellt nur der rahmen
den der israelische regisseur um diese
figur herum konstruiert der funktioniert
nicht zu sprechen
wirst ihn her bringen egal wie er ist
wie ein kind das sich beweisen werden er
hatte ich bereits benutzt um verbotene
technik zu schmuggeln
dazu kommt dass adlers regie es nicht
schafft diese diese agentinnen diese
frauen ihre einsamkeit wirklich zu
zeigen dass sie immer wieder wie aus
großer höhe und war wie aus großer
distanz beobachtet wird und dass dadurch
gerade das was für dein krügers spiel so
charakteristisch ist eben diese mischung
aus kühler und leidenschaft sie nicht
wirklich zur geltung kommt
du gibst einfach nichts von ihr preis
hast du ihn in seine wohnung mitgenommen
nein nach dieser partie sind wir zu ihm
gegangen
wir sehen sie immer wieder in vielen
weiteren situationen es gibt wunderbare
einzelne momente in diesem film aber
insgesamt ist es doch mehr oder weniger
ein marionettenspiel bei dem der
regisseur ein wenig ungelenk
ich bin ganz allein nur ich und der rest
der welt